what is the hardest problem
puzzle
idea in computer science for you
personally that you had to work through
just something that was just the
hardest thing that i've ever been
involved with yeah
okay well yeah that's i don't
know how to answer questions like that
but in this case uh it's pretty clear
okay because
it's uh
called the
the birth of the giant component okay so
now let me explain that because this is
actually gets
gets into physics too
and it gets into something called bose
einstein statistics but but
but anyway
it's got
some interesting stories and it
connected with berkeley again
um
so
start with the idea of a random graph
now this is
here we we just say we have n points
that are totally unconnected
and
and there's no geometry involved there's
no saying some points are further apart
than others all points are exactly
are exactly alike and
let's say we have 100 points and
and we number them from 0 0 to 9 9.
all right
now let's let's take pi uh the digits of
pi so
two at a time
so so we had 31 41 59 26 we we can look
go go through pi
and so
so we take the first two 31
41 and let's
let's put a connection between point 31
and point 41.
that's an edge in the graph so
then we take
five nine two six
and make another edge
and the graph gets bigger get gets more
and more
connected
as we add these things one at a time
okay so we started out with end points
and and we add uh
m edges
okay now each edge is completely
we forgot about that
edges we had before we make an edge
twice we might get an edge from a point
to it's selfie but
um you know maybe pi is going to
have a run of four digits in there
so we're gonna
but anyway
we're evolving a graph at random
and a magical thing happens
when the number of edges
is
like point four nine and
uh
so maybe n is a million
and i have
uh you know
490 000 edges
then
it almost all the time
it it consists of isolated trees
not even any loops right um it's a very
small number of veggies so far
about a little less than half n and
right but if i had point five one inches
so a little more than half and
so it's you know million points
510 000 edges
now it probably has
a
one component that's much bigger than
the others
um and we call that the giant component
is that can you clap so can you clarify
so
is there a name for this kind of random
super cool pie random graph
well i i call it
pot the pie graph no no i i
the pie graph is actually
my pie graph is based on
on binary representation of pi not the
decimal representation of pi but
but but but anyway
let's suppose i was rolling dice instead
exactly so sorry so it doesn't it
doesn't have to be pi
any source
the point is every step
choose totally at random one of those
end points
and choose totally at random another one
of those endpoints
make that an edge
that's the process yeah
so there's there's nothing magical about
pie they you know no i was using pie
i was sort of saying pie is sort of
random that nobody knows a pattern in
exactly i got it i got it but it's not
yeah i i could have just as well drawn
straws or something
this was a concept invented by erdeshan
rainey and they called the evolution of
random graphs and if you start out with
with a large number n
and you and you repeat this process all
of a sudden a big bang happens at one
half in there'll be two points together
then maybe we'll have half have three
uh
and then you know
then they maybe branch out a little bit
but but they'll all be separate until we
get to one half in
and we pass one half in and all of a
sudden
there's substance to it that
there are there's a big
clump of stuff that's all joined
together so it's almost like a phase
transition of some kind it's exactly it
it's a phase transition but it's
actually it's a double phase transition
it turns out it
it it happens
i mean there's actually two things going
on at once
at this phase transition which
uh which is very remarkable about it
okay so so um
a lot of the most important algorithms
are are based on random processes and so
i wanted to you know i want to
understand random processes now
so there are data structures that sort
of grow this way okay so
so dick carp one of the leading
experts on on random randomized
algorithms
had his students working looking at this
at berkeley
and we heard a rumor that the students
had found something interesting
happening
you know the the students are
are generating this
or simulating this random evolution of
graphs
and
under taking stat snapshots
ever so often
take a look at what the graph is
and the rumor was that every time they
looked
that there was only one component that
had loops in it almost always they do a
million experiments
and only
three or four times did they ever ever
happen to see a loop at at this point
uh i i mean no more than one component
with a loop
so they watch it till the graph gets
completely full
uh
so it starts out totally empty and gets
more and more
more and more edges all the time uh and
and so okay
certainly a loop comes along once but
but now all the loops
stay somehow joined to that one
they're never there never were two guys
with loops wow
okay in this experiment okay so anyway
almost always certainly not always yeah
but but but with high very high
probability this seemed to be true so
so we heard about this rumor at stanford
and we said
if that's true then must
you know
a lot more must also be true so there's
a whole bun there's a whole theory out
there waiting to be discovered that we
haven't ever thought about so so let's
take a look at this
and so we looked closer and we found out
no it actually
it's not true
but
but in fact
it's almost true
namely
there's a very short interval of time
when it's true
and and if you don't happen to look at
it
during that short interval of time
then you miss it
so
that in other words there'll be a period
where their two or three
components have loops
but
they join together pretty soon okay
so
if you don't have
a real fast shutter speed
you're going to miss you're going to
miss that incident so separate loops
don't exist for long that's that's it
yeah you know i started looking at this
to make it quantitative
and
basic problem was to slow down the big
bang so that i could watch it
happening yeah
i i think i can explain it actually
in fairly elementary terms
even without writing a formula that's
right like hawking would do uh and and
and so uh
let's let's watch the evolution and
and at first uh these edges are coming
along and they're just making
things without loops
which we call trees okay so then all of
a sudden a loop first appears
so at that point i have one component
that has a loop
all right now
now i say that the complexity of a
component
is the number of edges minus the number
of vertices
so if i have a loop
i have like a loop of length five
has five edges and five vertices
um or or i could put a tail on that
and that would be another edge another
vertex it's like a zero one two
complexity kind of thing so so if the if
the complexity is zero we have one
one loop i call it a cycle or i call a
cyclic component so so cyclic component
looks like
a
[Music]
a wheel
to which you attach
fibers
or trees
they go branching but there's no more
loops there's only one loop and
everything else
feeds into that loop okay
and that has complexity zero
but but a tree itself has complexity
minus one because it has
uh you know it like
like it might have ten vertices and nine
edges to tie the time together so nine
minus ten is minus one so so complexity
minus one is a tree
it's gotta be connected that's what i
mean by a component it's got to be
connected so so if
if i have 10 things connected i have to
have
nine edges
can you clarify why when complexity goes
uh you can go above zero i'm a little
yes
right so
the complexity plus one is the number of
loops
so if complexity is zero i have one loop
if if if complexity is one
that means i have one more edge then i
have verdicts
so i might have like
11
edges and 10 vertices
it's so it turns we call that a bicycle
because it it it's got two loops and
it's got to have two loops in it if
why can't it be trees just going off of
the loop
that i would need more edges than
all right right okay i got it so every
time i get another loop i i get
another excess of edges over vertices i
got you okay
so in other words uh
we start out and
after i have one loop i have one
component that has
a cycle in it not now the the next step
uh according to the rumor would be that
at the next step i would have
a bicycle
in in the evolution of almost all graphs
it would go from cycle to a bicycle but
in fact there's a certain probability it
goes
from cycle to two
you know
to two different cycles all right
um and i worked out the probability it
was something like 5 out of 24
there was pretty high
it was substantial yeah
but still
soon they're going to merge together
almost like okay so so
that's so cool but but then it splits
again
after you have either
either two or one one uh the next step
is you have either have three or you
have two one or you have one on one okay
and so i worked out the probability
for for those transitions
and
i worked it out up to
up to the first five transitions
and i had these so i had these strange
numbers 524s and i stayed up all night
and about 3 a.m
i
i
had the numbers computed and i looked at
them and here were
the denominator
was something like
20 2 3 0 2 3.
so
the probability was something over 2 3 0
2 3.
i don't know how you worked that out but
i had a formula that you know i could
calculate the probability yeah and and i
could find the limiting probability of n
goes to infinity and and it turned out
to be this number but the denominator
was two three and i and i looked at the
denominator and i said wait a minute
this number factors because
one thousand and one is equal to seven
times eleven times thirteen i had
learned that my first computer program
so
so so
so 23023
yeah is 7 times 11 times
13 times 23.
that's not a random number there has to
be a reason
why
those small primes appear in the
denominator
but my think
so all of a sudden that suggested
um
another way of looking at the problem
where small prime factors
would occur
so so what would that be so that said oh
yeah
let me take the logarithm of this
formula and and sure enough it's going
to simplify
and it happened so
and i wouldn't have noticed it except
for this factorization
okay so i go to bed and i i say oh okay
this is this looks like i'm slowing down
the big bang i can figure out what's
going on here
and the next day it turned out bill
gates comes to stanford to visit uh
they're trying to sell him on donating
money to uh for a new computer science
building sure and
and and uh so they gave me an
appointment to talk to bill and i
and i wrote down on the blackboard this
this evolutionary diagram you know going
from one to two five twenty fourths in
all this business yeah
and i wrote it down and anyway at the
end of the day the
uh he was discussing people with the
with the uh uh development office and
and he said boy i was really impressed
with what what professor knuth said
about this
giant component
and uh and so uh you know i i love this
story because it shows that
theoretic computer science is really
worthwhile you know
does bill have you ever talked to bill
gates about it uh since then
yeah
that's the cool that's a cool little
moment in history yeah but but anyway
he happened to visit on on exactly the
day after i had
i i had found this pattern and
and that allowed me to to crack the
problems you know so that i i could
develop the the
uh the theory some more and understand
what's happening in the big b but
uh
because i could i could now write down
explicit formulas for stuff right
and so it would you know it would work
not only the first few steps but also
they'll study the whole process and and
i worked further and further and i i
with two authors
co-authors and we finally figured out
that the probability
that
the rumor
was true in other words look at the
evolution of
of a random graph going from zero zero
to to complete
and say what's the probability that at
every point in time there was only one
component with a cycle
we started with this rumor saying
there's only one site there's only one
component with the cycle and and
uh
so
the rule was it's 100.
it turned out the actual numbers was
like 87 percent
i i don't know i should remember the
number but i do but i don't have it with
me but but anyway
but what the what the number
it it turned out to be like 12 over pi
squared or or anyway
so eight over pi anyway it it it was a
nice
it related to pi yeah um and we could
never have
done that with
but so that's the hardest problem i ever
saw in my life was to prove that this
probability is
it was proven
the probability was proven yeah i was
able to prove this that this
and and this should shed light on a
whole bunch of other things about random
graphs that that was sort of the
the major
thing we were asked after that's super
cool what was the connection to physics
that you mentioned
well bose einstein statistics is the
study of how
molecules
bond together
without geometry
without distance
you